so
i knew the operation was to be made
between rome and south america the
moment my father went to rome instead of
making the deposit a ban called the
in rome there was a change of route and
the deposit was made in the agency in
luano switzerland
i realized he wasn't involved with
conventional entrepreneurs
i realized that a year later when i was
arrested
[Music]
me
[Music]
there are no other goods allowing and
ensuring as much profit as cocaine does
profit
trafficking mainly enriches the
nurangita because on this market from
the brokerage of trafficking standpoint
it operates in a substantial monopoly
it was the dawn of june 18th 2015 when
cosimo tason a calibrian was arrested
he's a prominent figure of the
international drug trafficking the head
of a criminal group established in rome
for a number of years in a raid another
18 people were arrested with him
among them also several financial
brokers presumably responsible for
ensuring money laundering
this is a peculiar investigation because
only through this and very few other
inquiries we managed not only to
reconstruct the network of illegal drug
trafficking but also to retrace the
channels
through which passed the financial
resources necessary to the payment of
the huge amount of drugs that had been
brought to italy
necessary
italian
over the course of two years the police
seized over a ton of cocaine to the
criminal organization of cosimo teson
the seizures occurred in germany holland
belgium and italy agilia taro harbour in
calabria 2015 one thousand four hundred
container ships docked at gioya taro
about 1.6 million containers more or
less
we try to find the containers which may
conceal narcotics and i must say we also
made some big seizures
we found cocaine everywhere
we carried out a seizure recently
we found it in a container of aluminum
sheets for example
we did another seizure of 167 kilograms
the container carried bananas we could
say that the traffickers are getting
more sophisticated so we must try to
keep up with them
in line with the times that is
is everything okay
sure
why aren't they leaving
what the hell are they doing
it looks as if they know
they won't get out of the way
they found two boxes
they knew
[ __ ]
in the wire tappings the message of two
members of the roman group
it was march 29 2014
were ready to collect a drug shipment
preceded them
they seized 220 kilograms of cocaine
right under the nose
the loss of the shipment triggered the
anger and the suspicion of the boss
i am asking you you didn't take it
where the hell did it go was it seized
i sent you 2 million euros just like
that
the logistics of the organization was a
house in the outskirts of rome where the
affiliates brought the huge proceeds of
drug trafficking and then sorted them in
various money laundering operations with
the support of some above suspicion
financial brokers
hundreds of thousands of euros a week
in that house we recorded a few
encounters with white-collar workers but
they were crucial as a positive feedback
we managed to record periodically
at regular intervals the use of money
counting machines
it was a sound we heard in our
wiretappings
i'll get the money now and deliver it at
the usual place
yes
when will i get it in brazil
in a week
i want them in dollars
i'll contact someone i know
do you trust him
it once happened to me that we had
invested seven millions and a guy came
by with a woman and the money
disappeared with the woman so i went to
see her family and i took her children
two hours later and i mean two hours
exactly the woman was there and brought
[Music]
the drug trafficking money in south
america purchasing new batches of
cocaine
a well-oiled vicious cycle of dozens of
operations per month
the investigators managed to retrace one
of them for a total of 1.4 million euros
in may 2014.
to make this money transfer the head of
the clan turned to a former tuscan
financial advisor who involved his own
children in a deal
he still was an independent consultant
and had a client who had done
traditional finance operations
his client proposed him in operation
through an acquaintance of his in south
america
they had to bring money in brazil to
make some investments
in real estate
as far as i know that's what my father
told me
i'll outline the position of the father
which is the central one
there was no agreement at first on how
this transfer had to be made initially
the money was supposed to arrive in rome
and from rome through banco to brazil
they were going to
we're talking about an amount close to
1.5 million euros therefore it was a
violation of the anti-laundering
legislation they couldn't be transferred
at once and they thought about other
solutions
they agreed they needed something safer
that would allow to transfer the money
in the lump sum
which couldn't be done through the wire
transfer of renko duvezel
so they thought about physically taking
the money from rome to switzerland and
from there to brazil
so the father loaded the money on his
own car and drove to the swiss border
that's where two smugglers came into
play and took delivery of those 1.4
million euros cash stashed in two
suitcases
undisturbed they crossed the border and
once in switzerland they return the
suitcases to the middle person
from there my client made sure to
deposit the whole amount of money to the
agency
lugano
he made the deposit and got a receipt
the impression my client had was that
this place
first of all
he had been told that the place was safe
that such an operation could go smoothly
and that the person who received it was
accustomed to this kind of procedure
it was a mr raphael tonyaka
this mr rafael tonyaka unknown to my
client would then take care of the next
step from switzerland to south america
pursuant to an approach where the
sustainability of a business model has a
prominent role i am trying to develop a
wider strategy
a real multi-energy strategy starting
from our core business
in the oil sector
raphael tonyaka is an engineer from
belzona with a brilliant professional
and political career behind him
former president of the plr belzona
candidate to the grand council and
manager of the power company intesino
he held positions in leading energy and
oil companies in italy
we could say that it was all stemming
from a family relationship
the merging of two complementary figures
on one side the experience of an
international manager represented by
rafael taniaka and on the other a young
engineer with a prospective growth
represented by myself
[Music]
founded the viva group involving in the
project for a short period his cousin
flavio petraglio
the group consists of several companies
primarily engaged in real estate and
energy
part of this holding according to its
presentation on the internet is also
viva transfer
a money transfer agency of which on the
commercial registry the sole director
appears to be raphael toniaca's wife
and it was viva transfer that took
delivery of those 1.4 million euros sent
by kosimoto
viva transfer was a company of the group
which specifically dealt with money
transfers
on an operative level what i saw was a
number of individuals bringing their
money which was then sorted or
transferred rather through the banks to
the banks of the receiving countries
in particular i remember brazil surely
among the companies of the group viva
transfer was the one with the highest
profits
was a man who established himself abroad
and wasn't very well known here
abroad he operated in the field of
energy and renewable energy of major
importance then he came back
he had the profile we were looking for
to convince the younger generation of
liberals who are also somewhat green
in 2011 raphael tonyaka was backed into
politics and became one of the
candidates of the plr to the state
council
but his candidacy lasted a few days he
was asked to step back for his alleged
involvement in the legal proceedings
linked to his previous job in the energy
sector although the manager was not
under investigation
at first it took us all by surprise
such a newsworthy matter which then
folded and nothing came of
could you tell us why you left
i did not leave because of obvious
problems
before different views which were also
strategic without underlining who was
right and who was wrong
what i saw in the last months
was a will to intensify the activities
relating to brazil rather than to tesino
where professionally i feel more
connected and oriented
about the current case regarding the
alleged money laundering rafael tonyaka
did not wish to comment
his lawyer claimed that he was not under
investigation in switzerland or in italy
but rafael tonyaka and his wife the
presumption of innocent supplies
the fact is that according to the
italian investigation 1.4 million euros
cash were transferred from italy to
brazil through viva transfer a financial
intermediary in switzerland
according to the law against money
laundering
intermediaries should specify the origin
and the recipient of the money reporting
all suspicious cases
if this happened we do not know
the swiss anti-laundering authority
which we contacted did not comment
it's hard to think that someone
delivering to another person 1.4 million
euros cash would tell them
this is the money coming from and
delivered to me by x
whoever does this job know exactly what
they are doing
mainly there is also a problem about the
way the money was delivered since it was
1.4 million euros in cash
namely the way the money was received in
canton tesino
we took care of whatever brought it here
but the part that fell under our
jurisdiction
in switzerland did you get an answer
this is part of an ongoing investigation
at the moment i do not wish to comment
on it
we are sporn to secrecy on activities
under investigation
we asked the swiss magistrates but never
got an answer
the fact is that the italian financial
middlemen entered a plea bargain and are
waiting a trial
to them at one point this story had
turned into a real nightmare
we had recorded in the course of our
investigations that a relative had been
held hostage in brazil
as long as the transfer of money had not
been finalized
[Music]
his son flew to brazil he was taken and
brought to a hotel room where he was
told you are not moving from here until
we get the okay from the brazilian bank
what had been predicted does not go
through
that is the money did not arrive all at
once but came in installments
which made tassone and his men furious
who turned their first suspicions on my
clients
from one week his stay in brazil was
extended to one month where he received
the news from italy about tassone's men
taking some sort of increasingly heavy
pressure towards his father and his
brother
the operation did not go through
in the sense that the expected amount
was not transferred
the amount that was part of the deal
a lot less reached south america
right away i committed myself to prove
to the owner of the money that i knew
very little about it but surely my
father and my brother who was in brazil
were totally unaware of the possible
fraud
tell that fat man that if i don't get
the rest of the money i'll take his head
off first
and now live only to slaughter them
they messed with the wrong people
we are not entrepreneurs as they think
they were anything but friendly they
were aggressive both verbally and
physically and the situation started
worrying us because they were told i
gave the money to your family
people of a certain stature
that progressively reveals to be a
criminal stature
started arousing fear and putting them
under pressure obviously
at the time his brother was still in
brazil my client decided to go to
switzerland
he went twice to switzerland to
understand exactly what had happened
and give an explanation
to his tormentors because that's what
they were saying
on one of the trips i went with somebody
from rome
i wanted to go with this person to prove
there were no strange agreements
whatsoever between my father and the
people of the lugano agency
i realized that you're bound to imagine
anything at that point
my father had a receipt
but they could say
okay you did the deposit but how do i
know you don't have an agreement with
them
so i always try to make them understand
that my father did not pocket a euro
father
i talked twice to the wife of the owner
and i saw the owner once
they gave me the statements
it was a statement they called relator
of the wire transfers from switzerland
to brazil
with all the currency reports
they said they couldn't do the transfer
in one lump sum so they sent several
wire transfers
they said the law did not allow it
they talked about percentages of
commissions
all of that was managed by tonyaka in
the end not all of the money made it to
brazil
some 40 000 euro were missing and we
still don't know where they are
what happened to the rest of the money
that casimo tasono threw some middlemen
sent over to lugano agency
maybe the trial that should end in june
in italy will be able to tell
for sure
rafal tonyaka is not among the
defendants
the criminal organizations don't have
the means to channel this money through
what does it mean
it means that even in cocaine
trafficking which is typically a
criminal activity they need the help of
professionals to move their money and
they volunteer in passing through this
kind of financial resources
they use about 1.4 million euros in cash
this is the kind of things we should
take into consideration
because without the help of such
professionals that were identified the
money would have stayed in rome and
never would have gotten to brazil
[Music]
you